pour que le chef de l'Église
catholique marche avec eux dans
le long chemin de la guérison
èèès des mois de préparation,
le moment tant attendu est enfin
arrivé. Le pape François
a pu entendre de la bouche
des survivantetetete la douleur
associée aux pensionnats.
Une rencontre fructueuse,
où le pape a faitututututututut,
mais qui n'est que le début,
alors que des excu
se font toujours attendre.
L'Église a jadis voulu
les assimiler et les déposséder
de leur identité. d'd'd'd'hui,
les Métis sont venus au Vatican
en portant leurs couleurs et
traditionnels. Une victoire,
un a a a après
une journée forte en émotions
et en souvenirs douloureuxdededt
particulièrement émue après
sa rencontre p p p p pape.
Pendant longtemps,
les 65 0 d d d d du Canada
se sont sentis impuissants
face à l'Église et
au colonialisme. Le tête-à-têter
le rapport de force.
Leur rencontre a aussi été
qualifiée de positive par
les délégués, maaiaiaiaiaiaiaiae
quand le pape conf
sa venue au Canada,
une demande de longue date.
mimimimimimimimimimimimimimimimt
essentielle, selon cette
survivante
jjjjjjjjjjjjuaq. Martha Greig
souhaite que les Inuit
guérissent et puissent même
un jour pardonne
besoin d'entente l'acte
de contrition.
- Mathieu, cela dit, ce ne sont
pas tous les autochtones
qui sont prêts à pardonner, à se
réco
- Oui parce que, Geneviève,
quand on suit le
croire qu'il y a consensus,
justement, chez tous
chchchchchchchtones du Canada
avec cette idée de
réconciliation incluant l'église
et avec cette idée de main V V s
qu'on s'attend à des éventuelles
excuses. Aujourd'hui,
les délégués i
dû apporter une nuance assez
rarararararararappelant que
dans leur communauté, ce ne sont
pas tous les membres, ce ne sont
pas to q q q q q q q qui sont
d'accord avec cette idée
d'inclure l'église dautochtonest
simplement trop douloureux pour
même a
tout simplement pas qu'il y ait
des contacts, même, entre les
groupes autochtones et lsosososs
: les délégations qui sont ici
à Rome, elles sont absolument
réparation, à justement combler
shshshshshshshshship autochtone
demande depuisres
de la part du Pape. Mais c'est
important de souligner quand
même que les autochtones ne sont
n'y a pas un consensus, qu
ne sont pas 100 %
des autochtones au Canada
qui i i i i i i i i i i i i i is
ici présentement à Rome.
- Merci beaucoup,
Mathieu Gohier, au revoi